really your parents didn't want you to
act no they really I mean I can
understand because they knew what
Hollywood was they'd seen the good
they'd seen a lot of the bad yeah did
they really try to keep you away from it
no I think that's like a very it's a
story that's been like kind of like
telephone you know what I mean like one
article said it and then another one and
it's funny this person was asking me the
other day like so did what did they like
knock scripts out of your hand and I'm
like no it wasn't like they were that
against it they just didn't say either
way they wanted me to figure it out on
my own
but that being said the reason I said
that when I was like 19 or whatever the
[ __ ] I said that is that
I saw I think and this is still true I
saw how like unglamorous and sort of
painful it can be to be an actor and I
therefore never I like idolized it or it
wasn't like this dreamy thing that I was
like working towards like I just want to
be a star and be on a movie like it
wasn't like that for me and I don't know
if that's an annoying thing to say but
that's just what's true I saw the bad
side of it as well well your parents I
mean Kyra Sedgwick and Kevin Bacon I
mean classic
but I mean Friday the 13th I mean Friday
the 13th the horror movie The Knife to
the chest remember yeah of course the
neck the neck the neck the great CG on
that one yo yeah great seat but they
seem I I don't know if I'm right but
they seem the most normal as as you can
be as a couple in Hollywood they have
withstood the test of time in a lot of
ways yeah and they've stayed together
right yeah I mean that happens yes they
have no I'm not doing any reveals I mean
I don't know I don't have like a metric
for normal were you around celebrities
big celebrities your whole life no no no
they kept you waiting no like we just
lived in New York so like I grew up in
the city in Manhattan so like
for New York it's not cool to be an
actor right or a producer it's just not
like it's it's cool like it's not what
all the rich kids do parents do I'm like
you know what I'm saying out here it's
more of a thing so no I wasn't around
big celebrities ever I think I met
Howard Stern once and I was like oh my
God because we listened to Howard Stern
from when I was like four years old in
the house like I remember
so inappropriate like we it was always
on so I thought he was cool but I I
didn't know I did not it wasn't like
that really it wasn't like what like
maybe Willow Willow Smith's what life is
probably like you know what I mean like
those kids are real likes like their
their parents are celebrities and have
kind of chosen to live that put them out
there yeah but like with us we didn't no
I don't